exams a five-letter word which most of
us wished didn't exist but sadly
the truth is that exams are a vital part
of our lives
to progress further we all need to face
them
and ace them exams cause distress to
many
but exams are important they teach us
discipline
make us prepared for facing potential
situations
and also test our proficiency which on
the longer run
makes us a better person looking back at
my childhood and adulthood
i was fond of a lot of things playing
with my friends
sharing lunch sports traveling and of
course
biology but what i was not particularly
fond of
was exams now at this stage i see
a lot of people struggle with exams
they struggle not because they haven't
studied enough or due to a lack of
knowledge
but they struggle due to certain factors
which i plan to talk about in this video
hi my name is dr umar malik and this is
med simplified
let's talk about a few scientific ways
that will improve your exam preparation
and help you ace any exam you may face
number one planning most of the students
including me make this one simple
yet a very important thing we often
don't plan for how to prepare for an
exam
we just tell ourselves that we will
study as much as possible
and then hope for the best this isn't a
wise approach
preparing for an exam is like taking on
an important project
take for example building a bridge would
you start building a bridge without
first coming up with a plan
would you just begin construction and
hope for the best
no you wouldn't in a similar way it's
important to outline
in writing a strategy for how you'll get
ready for an exam
according to many scientific studies
brain adjusts to patterns
and predetermined tasks faster and also
more efficiently
rather than going about half as early so
keeping that in mind
here are some questions you should
consider as a part of your plan
when will you start studying how many
hours each day
will you dedicate to studying which
topics do you need further clarification
on
which homework assignments will you
review how many practice exams will you
do
how many times will you review your
notes and your textbook readings
what distractions are you likely to face
and how will you overcome them
as the saying goes failing to plan is
planning to fail
so make sure you have a plan for every
exam you take
draw up a list follow it religiously and
watch your performance boost
number two get on a sleep schedule at
least one week before the exam
many exams are scheduled for early in
the morning
a time when students don't usually feel
very awake
so it's always a better habit to start
sleeping earlier
at least one week before the exam so
that your body will have time to adjust
to this new schedule
if not your mind won't be in an optimal
state to take the exam
when you are sitting there giving the
exam you need your mind to be
on its peak performance so always ensure
you get
eight hours of sleep each night getting
enough sleep
is vital if you want to improve your
memory and mental focus
neuro studies have shown that when you
sleep the brain processes various
informations
from the previous day filtering out
important memories and consolidating the
information
it's tempting to stay up late or even
pull up
a few all-nighters in the days and weeks
leading up to the exam
but this is counterproductive you will
do much better on an exam if you get
adequate rest
to know how to sleep better and do's and
don'ts of sleep hygiene
watch our video on this topic by
clicking the banner above
number three don't do any last minute
studying
right before the exam it's common for
students to spend the last 10 minutes
before an exam
doing some last minute studying this may
provide some psychological comfort
but overall it does more harm than good
10 minutes before an exam you either
know the required information or you
don't
if you frantically review facts or
equations during this time
you will become more stressed and
anxious this will
negatively affect your performance
instead
make use of the time before the start of
the exam to relax
visualize yourself answering the
question correctly and imagine yourself
in a state of peace
and confidence as a college student i
always had a trick to calm myself down
before an exam
take a deep breath inhale for 4 seconds
and then exhale for 4 seconds repeat
this
as many times as necessary to calm down
trust me it will help a calm mind does
wonders
number four turn your focus towards the
process
and away from the outcome take a look at
professional athletes of
nba one second on the clock all the
pressure and cameras and
eyes on them imagine how intense it
becomes
at that moment when a player scores a
game-winning shot
when journalists ask them what was going
through your mind when you took that
shot
you might expect them to say something
like i thought about how the crowd would
react if i missed the shot
or i focused on how much time was left
in the game
but i've always observed that they
rarely say
anything like that their most common
reply is something like this
i just took the shot the same way i have
taken it thousands of times before in
the practice
it's this focus on the process and trust
on their hard work and practice
rather than the focus on the outcome
that allows professional athletes to
achieve
better outcomes this means that if you
focus
primarily on the outcomes for instance
repeatedly thinking to yourself
i must ace this exam i must ace this
exam
you're probably going to stress yourself
out and perform waivers
if you want to ace the exam you should
instead concentrate on staying calm
on thinking through each question
carefully and on analyzing
what each question is really asking
number five let's talk about some useful
exam taking techniques that you can
implement for better grades
students like to think that exams are an
objective measure of learning
but they're really not you might know
the information
but if you're not equipped with the
necessary exam taking skills
you won't get the grades you're hoping
for my seniors and elders taught this to
me
and i hope this helps you here are some
basic
exam taking principles and techniques
be familiar with the structure of the
exam it's important to know the answers
to these questions
how many sections will the exam have
what are the differences between the
sections
will there be multiple choice questions
open-ended questions
or both how many points will there be in
the total
use a stopwatch during an exam every
second counts
using a stopwatch will help you keep
track of the time
more accurately use a stopwatch during
your exam preparations as well
it will help you micromanage your time
and skills the inner clock
look through the entire exam at the
beginning when the exam starts
don't jump straight in and start
answering the questions
instead take a minute or two to skim all
of the questions
get a feel for how challenging the exam
is overall
and take a note of which questions will
be especially time consuming
set aside more time to tackle those
questions
this will avoid any surprises you may
feel as you go deeper
into the exam know how much time
you should spend on each question based
on how long the exam is
and how many points there are in total
you'll know roughly
how much time to spend on each question
for example
if you have 50 minutes to complete a 50
point exam
you have one minute per point so
for a 10 point question you should spend
approximately 10 minutes answering it
if after 10 minutes you're still not
done with the question
it's time to speed up if you get stuck
move on if you are unable to solve a
problem
maintain your composure and go on to the
next one
time is always ticking when you have
completed the rest of the exam
come back to the unfinished problems
that way
even if one part doesn't work out for
you you can utilize time to the past you
know
and can easily score from with that we
come to the end of this
short video friends i want all of you to
work hard and succeed in life
i hope this video helps you in that
process
make sure to hit the like button below
and make sure to share this video with
your friends
subscribe to our channel if you're new
we at mess simplified are committed to
bringing you
new quality content every week support
us by becoming a member of our channel
on youtube or patreon.com slash med
simplified
also you can connect to us through
instagram where we post something new
and fun
every day links are in the description
below
thank you so much for watching and stay
safe see you
in the next video